if you don't actually experience it
there is no way to describe the feeling
of having your name called when the
presenter opens the envelope and reads
what is written on the card our next two
presenters know what it's like to be in
that position they may not remember the
actual announcement or how they managed
to get on stage and up to the microphone
to accept the Oscar they may not
remember whom they thanked or forgot to
thank or what they said or even who
handed them the award boy this is long
but they know for sure it really
happened and then like did it not not
happen and then it did could this like
be like so crazy like I didn't write
this and then the next morning they was
like and like this is like bull what is
this holding a sword in their room it
wasn't that the night before what did
that mean it was no I wasn't that good
but that's what was it huh okay didn't
inhale one
come on
and I may believe I had a good time
right
not one earned her Oscar for cabaret and
the other got hers for terms of
endearment two of Oscars chosen few Liza
Minnelli and Shirley MacLaine
thank you we've now heard and seen all
five of the selected nominations for
Original Score they have all come from
three different films but each of those
films has something in common they made
a lot of money something else well they
all deal with dramatic subject something
else we weren't in any of them
yes so Liza why don't you and I and some
other real live human beings next year
get together and make a musical of our
own all right yes you know we should get
that other buddy of ours I mean that you
know the singer the actress that girl
over there the funny girl a director
right the director that we would most
like to work with
some other life now
this year the nominees were original
song are from Beauty and the Beast
Beauty and the Beast
music by Alan Menken lyric by Howard
Ashley from Beauty and the Beast billed
music by Alan Menken lyric by Howard
Ashman from Beauty and the Beast
be our guest music by Alan Menken lyric
by Howard Ashman from Robin Hood Prince
of the thieves everything I do I do it
for you
music by Michael paymon lyric by Bryan
Adams and Robert John Lang from hook
when you're alone music by John Williams
lyric by Lesley British the Oscar goes
to Alan Menken and Howard Ashman for
Beauty and the Beast from Beauty and the
Beast
on behalf of Howard I know if you were
here he'd want to thank Angela Lansbury
for her incomparable performance of the
song in the movie as mrs. potts
and also Celine Dion and Peabo Bryson
for their performance also thanks to
Walter I and Robin Buchanan for their
work on the single and accepting for
Howard will be billed out Howard and I
shared a home and a life together and
I'm very happy and very proud to accept
this for him
but it is bittersweet this is the first
Academy Award given to someone we've
lost to AIDS in working on Beauty and
the Beast
Howard faced incredible personal
challenges but always gave his best and
what made that possible was an
atmosphere of understanding love and
support that's something everyone facing
AIDS not only needs but deserves there's
an inscription at Howard's grave in
Baltimore
it reads oh that he had one more song to
sing we'll never hear that song but I'm
deeply grateful for this tribute you've
given to what he left behind for Howard
I thank you
mr. Michael Douglas